hello very good morning to you and we
start with that breaking news as the
energy regulator ofgem announces the new
price cap for fuel bills in england
wales and scotland so from october the
energy price cap will increase to 35
pounds and that's a huge rise from the
current
1971 pounds per year that's been in
force since april well let's get
reaction straight away from our business
correspondent helen and smith who's
embarking in east london so helen ann
smith a huge rise in the price cap 3549
pounds
hitting people's bills from october just
as was feared
yeah that's exactly right anna it's a
hugely important morning very
significant and i think very frightening
for a lot of people up and down this
country who have been knowing that this
price cap is coming this price cap rise
has been coming knowing that autumn is
on its way and feeling very worried
indeed about how they're going to pay
their bills through the coming winter so
we know now just how much that cap is
going to go up by
3549 pounds a year will be the typical
uh price of an average person's bill
that is the cap that off gems say the
maximum that they can charge just to
sort of clarify what that cap involves
uh it is a cap on essentially the unit
of energy that each of us will buy that
off gem say that the energy companies
are allowed to sell plus the standing
charge so essentially it is the maximum
amount that a typical bill uh is allowed
to cost essentially just important to
stress though your bills could be
slightly more than that or slightly less
than that depending on how much energy
you use it's also the price for what's
called a default tariff or a standard
variable tariff as that's the sort of
tariff that you're on worth saying that
people on pre-payment meters will also
have a rise to their cap as well it will
be slightly different to this number
that we're talking about and once we get
that full release from off gen we'll go
through those numbers and we'll bring
them um to you as well but look i think
it's important to take a step back and
put this number in some context this is
in roughly the region of 80 percent in
terms of the amount that bills are
rising from what they currently are now
they're currently
just shy of 2 000 pounds a year rising
by roughly 80 percent so that is a
hugely significant rise and compare that
to last winter because remember the
price of the bills now came into force
in april so last time last october the
cap that was in force throughout last
winter i mean we're talking about now
two and a half times as much this winter
roughly uh and so a huge huge difference
for people in their lives in a very
frightening time indeed the causes and
the reasons we've covered them a lot
anna but i think it's worth just
reiterating uh the big driver in all
this is the massive surge in the price
of wholesale gas
those prices of wholesale gas were
rising before the russian invasion of
ukraine but that is the big factor uh
that have caused them to absolutely
skyrocket to record highs in recent
months they really peaked back in the
spring when that invasion happened but
they have started really rising up again
to roughly what they were when the
invasion happened and the reason for
that is there's a a sense and a fear
that lots of companies across europe are
trying to hedge trying to gather in buy
as much energy they can ahead of the
winter but also a sense that russia is
flexing its muscles uh we know that next
week uh the pipeline the big pipeline
that's called nordstrom one it carries
russian gas to europe it's being shut
off for three days the russians say
that's because of maintenance but the
markets fear that it's a threat in terms
of how russia wants to behave in terms
of its selling of gas to europe it sells
some 40
of european gas in the eu comes from
russia it certainly did before the war
so a hugely significant supply and that
is what caused prices to skyrocket but
of course if you're a customer at home
that's not going to make you feel much
better
and that wholesale price unfortunately
your household energy company your
consumer-facing energy company people
that you buy your energy from
they are in a position where
they have to pay those exorbitant prices
to buy their gas they have to pass that
on to their customers or they risk
going out of business and then going out
of business would make the whole
situation worse so we are in this very
critical position the only option really
for people is for the government to do
more to try and mitigate some of that
impact of these huge huge rising bills
both candidates have indicated very
strongly that they will do something
what that is remains to be seen and of
course many people say it might all come
in quite late it takes a long time to
implement these sort of measures so
nerve-wracking news indeed today the
energy price cap up in a region of about
80
3549 pounds a year for the typical bill
yeah hello now thanks very much indeed
it's news isn't it that affects so many
of us so let's just reiterate that
breaking news for you that we've just
got in the last few moments offgem has
announced that the energy price cap is
going to go up to
3549 pounds from october now that's a
huge jump the price cap is currently set
at
1971 so it's roughly an 80 percent rise
there to the energy cap
so let's just look at what the energy
cap is and how does it affect you so it
sets the maximum price that companies
can charge for each unit of energy
energy that a household uses on a
standard variable tariff so it doesn't
limit your total bill it only reflects
typical usage so if you use more units
you will be charged more
the cap used to be reviewed twice a year
but now it's going to happen every three
months and it applies across england
wales and scotland
so let's stick with the story and get
some reaction to the new energy price
cap i'm joined now by adam scorer who's
the chief executive of the fuel poverty
charity national energy action
very good morning to you adam scorer
thanks so much for talking to us so
we've just heard the new energy price
cap roughly in line with the predictions
3549 pounds from october what's your
reaction
well it's confirmation of some very very
bad news and it will be extremely
worrying as we look into
winter and the cost that households will
face but it will be terrifying when you
actually get into winter so 80 percent
more that's 750 pounds more than the
off-gen projection in may on which the
chancellor based the price support
package so we're not only seeing the
size of the average bill we're seeing
the inadequacy of the support that's
available for for the households on the
lowest incomes that are most vulnerable
to these price rises
well yeah give us some more of an idea
of what this means for them we've had
various warnings about what the winter's
going to mean for
those less well-off
in the country yesterday the resolution
foundation said that rising bills will
lead to more deaths through the cold
weather what's your prediction for what
this price rise could mean
resolution foundation are absolutely
right there is a hard connection between
people who live in cold and damp homes
and around 10 000 people every year who
died of the effect of those cold homes
we'll have million more homes that will
not be heated this winter it's a pretty
simple equation that leads to more ill
health it leads to more death i pay by
direct debit my costs are spread across
the year if you're paying by a
prepayment meter not only are you paying
more than the average cap that you you
mentioned the cap for the direct debit
costs but you're paying as you use it so
in january the really intense month the
average
someone on a meeting could be paying 600
pounds for a decent level of warmth and
of course the consequences they just
won't heat their homes and they won't
heat their water they won't give their
children baths they won't cook hot food
the privation
will be enormous if people want to avoid
impossible levels of debt
so what needs to be done
i mean quite simply we need a big and
proportionate response firstly from
government uh we haven't really seen
something of the scale of this before at
the very very least they've got to
double the price support package they
announced in may they've got to work
with the regulator to bring a social
tariff in to make this to hardwire
supporting for vulnerable households
they've got to deliver and then
manifesto commitments on energy
efficiency for the uh for the war homes
and and they just got to think big this
is a systemic problem it explodes our
welfare benefit safety net people cannot
afford no choices no scrimping no
cutting back simply cannot afford price
like price rises at this level
and the government has made clear that
no policy will be announced until the
new prime minister takes over in a
couple of weeks time
do you have sympathy with that and do
you have confidence that two leadership
candidates
understand the scale that you says this
issue is standing at i had zero sympathy
for the government's approach on this um
we didn't need to wait to today to know
what the the level of the price cut was
going to be it was projected with a
great deal of certainty and accuracy
some months ago knowing the last penny
is no excuse the the steps i've
mentioned before are with the grain of
established government policy it could
just be to add to those to deliver a
decent support the earlier you get the
support package announced the earlier
you can think about the logistics of
delivering it and make sure that people
don't fall through the gaps if we have
to wait until the 5th of september when
the new prime minister
is announced then it needs to be the
first thing they do and they had better
done some work in the background to
prepare themselves because everything so
far has been inadequate short-term
poorly targeted or just not
comprehending the scale of the impact
this will have for households especially
especially when we hit the heating
season uh in winter
but do you trust that liz truss or rishi
sunak will handle this adequately do you
have trust that they will
if you look at what they've said so far
i think rishi sunak has announced that
he will build on his support package
that's short term but it is targeted and
it will kind of take the sting out of
the tail as we head into sting out of
the the bite of these price rises as we
head into winter but to be honest um
i've seen nothing material from liz
trust
it's either poorly targeted and wholly
inadequate or based on some uh future
mythic um kind of idea of of supply
resilience so uh neither of them have
either got the
the scale of it the lent the duration of
this crisis
and the the the notion that we need to
think big and bold and differently about
how we protect some of the most
vulnerable households in the uk quite
simply from from devastation as we head
into the winter
well yes and this trust us today said
that she's pledging immediate support
hasn't she but we haven't got more
details yet of what that will involve
logistics need to be put in place to
deliver these things the later you leave
it the more difficult that delivery
becomes and the more likelihood that it
will be full of holes and will be
inadequate there is no value in delay
okay and what about what companies can
do we focus on what politicians might be
able to do we have seen british gas
saying that it will put 10 percent of
its profits towards helping more
vulnerable customers
do you welcome that i mean the amount
that it produces is perhaps not going to
solve the problem but would you see more
like to see more companies do take
action like that
i welcome that commitment from from
british gas we know it won't really
touch the sides but it's an important
commitment from a company that is still
making profits in the retail uh
market but what they've got to do the
basics though they've got to make sure
that they do not impose prepayment meter
on people struggling for debt because
that will make their situation worse
they've got to have a really
sensitive approach to debt recovery
they've got to reach out and support
those households especially those in
vulnerable conditions kind of older
households households with medical
dependencies or disabilities to make
sure they're alert to the issues that
they will have just struggling to try
and make these bills they've got to step
forward and reach out and support their
customers but the basics of this is it's
down to government it's down to
government to step in and prevent of
cost of living crisis becoming a cost in
lives crisis over the winter
what about the regulator it's them
who've announced this this price cap
this rise of around 80 percent what do
you make of how ofgem is handling this
and is the price cap fit for purpose
after him i've got a lot of work to do
um i think the price cap of course was
introduced to ensure that people who
weren't active in the market didn't get
an outrageous bill it wasn't meant to be
a fuel poverty measure and it's [ __ ] and
it's creaking it's showing that it's not
really up and nothing was really up for
uh price rises of this scale but offgem
has got to really enforce
the the regulations that require energy
suppliers to treat their vulnerable and
low-income households fairly it's got to
think about social tariffs ways of of
instituting at the heart of our
regulatory environment greater
protection for those on the lowest
incomes it's got to think harder about
how we make sure that if you're on a
prepayment meter you're not so
disadvantaged in the market and so
likely to cut yourself off from gas it's
got a lot of work to do in many ways
this crisis is so unprecedented that the
the provisions we've had for good years
are just blown away by this crisis but i
think they should have done more to be
honest i think they should have done
more on the standing charge so that
means if you are either you have to cut
back or you are cutting back you're
still seeing an excessive rise because
of what's loaded into the standard try
so lots of things that the regulator
needs to do and the companies need to do
but come on it's government this is a
this is a crisis of the poorest
households in our society facing
armageddon over the winter it is only
government that can step in and make
sure this isn't disastrous over the
winter and next winter as well
and finally what's your advice to those
who are worried about the months ahead
and being able to pay their bills
i wish i could give some real proper
advice my single piece of advice if and
millions will be in this situation it
looks like you just simply cannot afford
the bill just
get in touch with your supplier
acknowledge the situation you're in if
you are in debt get a debt repayment
plan that meets your needs get all the
advice that you can
there's things that everyone can do if
you can turn your thermostat down by one
degree that's great you can close your
curtains when it gets at dusk that's
great there's other things that you can
do but they're marginal they're marginal
if you fear getting into problem debt
get in touch with your supplier early as
you can to set a repayment plan that
meets your needs and get all the advice
and support you can from from other
organizations
okay adam scorer thanks very much indeed
uh for joining us here this morning and
giving your instant reaction to that new
energy price cap of
3549 pounds adam scorer thanks very much
indeed
so now we know just how high energy
bills are going to rise this autumn with
campaigners calling for urgent action
from the government as you heard there
to help millions of struggling
households well the chancellor has just
released a statement in response to this
saying i know the energy price cap
announcement this morning will cause
stress and anxiety for many people but
health is coming with 400 pounds off
energy bills for all the second
installment of a 650 pound payment for
vulnerable households and 300 pounds for
all pensioners
while putin is driving up energy prices
in revenge for our support of ukraine's
brave struggle for freedom i'm working
flat out to develop options for further
support and this will mean the incoming
prime minister can hit the ground
running and deliver support to those who
need it most as soon as possible so
that's the chancellor statement in
response to the energy price cap
announcement in the last few moments so
let's uh bring in our political
correspondent amanda akas now
we had there from adam scorer
calling on more action from the
government um but we're not going to get
any new plans are we until there's a new
prime minister installed yes indeed so i
think all of this will really pile more
pressure on the two leadership
candidates to really set out in detail
exactly how they're going to help
households budget for this very
difficult winter ahead and indeed as you
say really highlights this power vacuum
at the top of government is still 11
days until the new prime minister will
take office and begin to even be able to
start taking action what might that be
well we've had some
interesting slight change of attack
from liz truss overnight um throughout
the campaign she's been stressing of
course the way to help people the cost
of living is cutting taxes she's been
quite dismissive of the idea of handouts
as she's described them but now writing
in the daily mail she says she knows
knows exactly how hard it is for people
uh dealing with this crisis um and says
um to those of you feeling the squeeze
my message is clear i will ensure
support is on its way to get you through
these tough times so her team have
rather been signaling over the past week
that they were moving towards offering
some kind of additional support this is
really the very clearest signal that she
has really changed tac quite
dramatically from where she was at the
start of this leadership campaign
clearly the pressure of what's been
happening really has been getting to her
now rishi sunak her rival on the other
hand i mean first of all he says
offering a big package of support as
well as the tax cuts well that will lead
to inflation which will make everything
worse he
all along really has been pledging um
additional support for the most
vulnerable so uh people on low incomes
and pensioners along the lines of the
kind of package that he put in place
when he was chanced at the exchequer but
neither of them still are willing to
give us really any details on what
exactly they might be able to give
people even in that statement we heard
there from the chancellor he says more
help is on its way but those figures the
400 pounds or 650 pounds that's what was
already announced back in the
back in march so it's not new although
it is now coming in and of course the
situation has got much worse since then
so i think that's what quite crucial
that he is saying the treasury are
working up different options for the
next prime minister when they do come in
now interestingly as well yesterday he
ruled out um or said he certainly
doesn't support the idea of a uh freeze
on the energy prices and neither um liz
trust will mr sunak neither of them
support this either there are two
proposals on the table for that so labor
of course saying we're going to freeze
bills for six months and that would cost
30 billion pounds paid for by a windfall
tax on the energy companies the energy
companies themselves are proposing
a freeze for two years which would cost
around 100 billion pounds that would be
paid for by the government which should
have a huge long-term impact on
taxpayers because we'd all be paying for
that for many years to come mr zahawi
says support needs to be more targeted
but we know a sky news poll yesterday
suggested a third of households are
already struggling to pay their bills
this is only going to get much much
worse um so really with the new prime
minister coming into office in 11 days
time i think action can't come soon
enough
indeed amanda and uh yeah we'll be
exploring this throughout the morning of
course thanks very much indeed uh well
lots still come on the show and at eight
o'clock i'll be speaking to the chief
executive of off gem about that new
price cap meanwhile as more than a
hundred thousand postal workers walk off
the job this in the summer of strikes
i'm gonna be speaking to their union
leader dave ward
and i'll also speak to the royal males
chief executive simon thompson about how
long services will be disrupted
in fact let's find out a little bit more
about that postal strike right now shall
we
skies over bennett joins me now from the
picket line in east london so either
tell us a little bit about what this
strikes all about and how people are
going to be impacted
yeah another another day another strike
this is being billed as the biggest of
the summer so far with 115 000 royal
mail workers uh walking out across the
uk this picket line is one of 1500
although i'm not sure how many others
can uh boast
a special guest behind me you might be
able to make out postman pack there but
no sign of his bright red van i'm afraid
because anyone who is planning to post
anything today uh or is waiting for
something to arrive may have to wait a
little bit longer because anything
posted yesterday today or tomorrow is
likely to be delayed uh royal mail have
said they're going to prioritize certain
things like medical prescriptions but
disruption
is expected now the main bone of content
contention in this dispute like with
many of the other disputes we've seen
over the summer
is over pay
royal mail say they've offered workers
up to a five and a half percent pay rise
but the union behind this the
communication workers unions say that's
not enough they say they want something
uh more in line with the current rate of
inflation which is around ten percent uh
it's set to rise to 13 according to the
bank of england and they want something
to reflect the rising cost of living
which we've been hearing so much about
of course this morning um and they say
they still haven't been properly
recognized for their work during the
pandemic when they were key workers now
separate to this there is also a strike
being organized by post office workers
with around 2 000 walking out in in
branches across the uk so a lot of
disruption today to the postal system
and more disruption expected with three
more walkouts by royal mail staff
organized over the next two weeks
either thanks very much indeed for that
now the family of olivia pratt corbell
have appealed for people to do the right
thing to help police find her killer the
nine-year-old was shot in her home in
liverpool on monday night and a huge
murder investigation is now underway to
track down her killer
well skies at shingi mararike is in
liverpool for us this morning so shinki
what's the latest on the police
investigation what are they saying
morning anna so that statement from
her family giving you a sense as to the
grief that they're feeling and also a
sense as to the little girl that olivia
was who enjoyed playing on the street
and as they described as a nine-year-old
going on 19 and i have their statement
with me or part of it liv was adored by
everyone who knew her and would
instantly make friends of anyone and
everyone she was often seen going up and
down the street on her new bike she had
just got for her birthday
we as a family are heartbroken and have
lost a huge part of our life if anyone
knows anything now is the time to speak
up it is not about being a snitch or a
grass it is about finding out who took
our baby away from us please do the
right thing and you asked about the
police investigation that sentiment has
been echoed by the police as well over
the last few days they've been asking
people to come forward and yesterday in
a briefing they said that they are
following several positive lines of
inquiry we know that joseph knee was a
man who was arrested uh for breaching
his license conditions he was the man
who tried to force his way into the
house and was then taken away in a black
audi as olivia lay dying we also know
through the police that the man who he
was with who was approached by a gunman
who who he was with when he was
approached by a gunman has also been
spoken to and identified as were the men
in that audi the police also spoke about
two other murder investigations going on
in liverpool and five arrests have been
made in connection to those but this is
obviously now a massive manhunt and we
don't have the name of the suspect in
the killing of olivia and now not just
the police but her family are asking
people to come forward and do the right
thing
shinki thanks very much indeed
let's take a look at some of the day's
other headlines
and a host pipe ban for around five
million people across yorkshire comes
into force today yorkshire water says
many areas have seen their lowest
rainfall since records began more than
130 years ago
the head of the raf has said he'll
address questions raised over diversity
targets in the air force along with
allegations of sexual harassment and
bullying within the red arrows air chief
marshal sir mike wigston said anyone
with concerns about activity within the
service should raise it with their chain
of command alert a confidential helpline
or tell the raf police
a redacted version of the affidavit used
for the search of donald trump's
mar-a-lago estate is set to be made
public later on today it's likely to
contain key information about why fbi
agents search the president's property
and some of the evidence that the
government presented to the judge
mark zuckerberg has revealed that
facebook suppressed articles about a
story concerning the son of u.s
president joe biden during the 2020
election
conservatives accused facebook of
censoring the story about hunter biden's
laptop
speaking to podcaster joe rogan mr
zuckerberg confirmed they limited shares
of the story after the fbi warned
facebook of russian propaganda
if something is reported to us as
potentially
misinformation important misinformation
we also this third party fact-checking
program because we don't want to be
deciding what's true and false and
for the
i think it was
five or seven days when it was basically
being
um
being determined whether it was false
um the distribution on facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it when i say
the distribution has decreased it got
shared how does that work basically the
ranking and news feed was a little bit
less so fewer people saw it than would
have otherwise so it definitely by what
percentage i don't know off the top my
head but it's it's it's meaningful
president zielinski has said the world
narrowly avoided a radiation disaster
when ukraine's zaparisia nuclear power
plant which is occupied by russian
forces was disconnected from the
national grid the ukrainian leader
claimed russian shelling had caused a
fire which led to the reactor being cut
off
diesel generators immediately started
providing energy to support it after the
shutdown
the world must understand what a threat
this is if the diesel generator had not
been turned on if the automation and our
station staff had not worked after the
blackout we would now be forced to
overcome the consequences of a radiation
emergency
russia has put ukraine and all europeans
one step away from radiation disaster
well our defense and security editor
debra haynes is in the capital kiev for
us this morning so deborah there seems
to be real concern about this nuclear
plant
yes it's been uh it's been a worry a
worry hasn't it for the last in
particular in the last few weeks when
there's been uh from the ukrainian side
uh accusing the russian forces of
shelling
onto the plant and clearly
were any kind of attack to happen that
would impact the reactors there then
that's obviously why
the country is so worried it's the
largest nuclear energy plant in europe
and so the consequences of a disaster
there i mean people in this country are
no stranger unfortunately to nuclear
disaster given that they lived through
the chernobyl uh uh horrors in 1986 um
but clearly that's in their mind when
they're looking at what's happening
around zaparizia um on the russian side
they were blaming ukrainian forces for
some kind of fire that triggered this
plant being disconnected
from the energy grid and that energy is
needed to be fed into the plant in order
to keep power on the various safety
mechanisms that keeps that plant safe
now while the disaster was averted
yesterday
the the battles around the plant are
continuing and every day it goes on the
risk remains of a disaster happening the
un's uh nuclear energy watchdog the iaea
has been trying to get access to the
plant and the ukrainian side that that
has said that they hope that could
happen soon it hasn't happened yet and
as long as this plant remains out of
the control or the scrutiny of the
international community then it's
clearly going to be a huge problem it's
been effectively under russian control
since since march there are ukrainian
officials in the plant uh being held
there while they obviously have to keep
um maintaining their vital work to keep
the plants safe it must be a horrendous
situation for them too and it is yet
another reminder of the of the byproduct
of this war that's gripped this country
now for more than six months
and with parts of the world experiencing
some extreme weather conditions let's
take a quick look at the impact of
climate change on the planet and show
you our data dashboard here at the right
hand side of this screen shows how the
uk's power is currently being produced a
lot of focus on gas this morning with
the price cap being announced 61
of our power currently coming from gas
at the moment and here on the top left
you can see how much warmer the earth is
now than in 1880 that's when records
began the industrial revolution
essentially
1.256 the figure there and this is the
amount of co2 emissions being pumped out
globally at the moment in millions of
tons and you can see that numbers rising
all the time there
hello welcome back let's get more now on
the breaking news this morning about the
energy price cap fuel bills are set to
increase by more than 1 500 pounds from
the average family from october
it's rising to 3
549 pounds
so let's take you through what the
energy price cap is and how it might
affect you so it sets the maximum price
that companies can charge for each unit
of energy that a household uses on a
standard variable tariff so it doesn't
limit your overall bill if you use more
units you'll be charged more
the cap used to used to be reviewed
twice a year but now it happens every
three months and it applies across
england wales and scotland affecting an
estimated 22 million households on a
variable tariff and the new cap will
take effect from
october the first
now most of what you pay goes towards
wholesale costs the rest is for things
like green levees and vat
and this puts things into some
perspective today's significant jump to
3549 pounds
towers over previous increases
so what is the government doing so far
to help well all households will be
given a one-off 400 pound discount on
their fuel bills in october and 650
pounds will be paid to more than 8
million low-income households who
receive benefits pensioners and
individuals with disabilities will
receive further help
well speaking to the programme in the
last hour the chief executive of the
fuel poverty charity national energy
action said the rise could lead to a
million more homes not being heated this
winter adam scorer said a big response
is needed from the government to prevent
the cost of living crisis becoming a
cost of lives crisis
there is a hard connection between
people who live in cold and damp homes
and around 10 000 people every year who
died of the effect of those cold homes
will have million more homes that will
not be heated this winter it's a pretty
simple equation that leads to more ill
health it leads to more death this is a
systemic problem it explodes our welfare
benefit safety net people cannot afford
no choices no scrimping no cutting back
simply cannot afford price like price
rises at this level
so let's get more reaction to that new
energy price cap and what it'll mean for
households across the country
joining me now is kim eldridge who
campaigns for don't pay uk
very good morning to you kim eldridge
what do you make of this news price cap
3549 pounds
give us an idea of how it could affect
you and your family for example
yeah i'm really upset that the price cap
has hit the 80 that they predicted it's
you know
it's just shocking so don't pay uk the
website has loads of information on it
my mum is she's struggling you know
she's she's disabled she's on benefits
and she already can't afford her bills
they've gone up to 118 pound a month
from 55 last year she cannot afford it
the
this price cap it's just crazy she was
already talking to my granddad about
having to move in with him this winter
to be able to
you know heat one home rather than
heating two homes this increase
genuinely means debt or death for a lot
of people people are gonna fall into
debt with their energy companies or
they're gonna freeze to death in their
homes
well and there are a lot of people like
your family very worried about how they
will pay their bills
this winter but
tell us why you think that
not paying your bills is the right
approach there are there are warnings
around aren't there that if you don't
pay your bills that debt will follow you
around i mean there's a risk of legal
action there's a risk of not being able
to borrow money in future that will
affect your credit rating is this the
right approach do not risk penalizing
yourself as much as the energy companies
that is a great point but you know what
i think there's a lot of fear-mongering
around this people simply can't afford
it my mom doesn't have that money coming
in so it's a matter of her not paying
now or what getting into debt over the
winter anyway so it absolutely makes no
difference for her when she gets into
debt with the energy company and we're
asking a million people to sign this
pledge on the don't pay dot uk website
we all deserve to have a warm home this
wednesday you know schools need to be
heated this winter okay well apologies
there if you missed some of the rest at
the end of that interview there i was
talking there to kim eldridge from don't
pay uk and if she didn't hear me thank
her thanks very much indeed
for that
let's move on though more than a hundred
thousand royal male postal workers have
gone on strike in a dispute over pay
members of the communication workers
union said the two percent pay rise
imposed on them by management was not
good enough well i'm joined now by the
general secretary of the communication
workers union dave ward dave what a very
good morning to you
uh first of all give us a sense of the
size and scale of the action that you're
taking today and the levels of
disruption it's likely to cause
sorry it's difficult to hear um yeah
sorry say that again
just wanted to get you to give me a
sense of the scale of the action that
you're taking today and the levels of
disruption it's likely to cause
yeah okay so there's 115 000 postal
workers taking strike action today it's
the biggest strike in the uk since 2009
it's also probably the biggest mandate
that any union has ever had for strike
action over 97.7
members voted in favor of strike action
on a 77
turnout
our members are really really angry and
have lost all confidence in the
leadership of the company the company
made 758 million pound profit record
profits for royal mail last year they
gave away chose to gave away over 400
million pounds to shareholders they
rewarded themselves with huge record
bonuses apparently for achieving all
their financial targets and then they
imposed a two percent pay increase on
the workforce and against skyrocket in
inflation uh energy bills rocketing um
people are just not going to accept that
and i think that what's really a shame
here is that this is a group of workers
in the uk
that we would argue are one of the last
remaining pillars of our society they're
part of the social fabric of the uk
they have a fantastic relationship with
customers which is the company's
greatest asset
and it is unbelievable that the company
have chosen to treat our members in this
way so you know we're going to fight
very hard here
to get the pay rise that our members
deserve
well yes you say they're making record
profits royal mail says your proposals
would cost a billion pounds well it's
losing almost a million pounds a day
they say that
their business is suffering there are
fewer covered tests being delivered for
example there are a few people shopping
online post pandemic
and there's a steeply declining letter
market and they simply have to be able
to compete with with some of their
competitors so that's reasonable isn't
it
anna anna listen i i wish you could get
royal mao
to debate these issues and the statement
that you've just read out
because we would take that debate
anywhere any place any time and to point
out that it's a total fabrication of the
truth of what's going on in this company
and these people are being less than
honest with you less than honest with
their customers and and you know it's
just not on i mean they made record
profits they have said that their
bonuses uh were achieved because they
hit all of their financial targets and
yes there are some issues we understand
that
we will never face away from change it's
our union that wants to get on and do
the right change that protects the
company for the future but the company
has stood those talks we've got a second
ballot on change because they've walked
away from the agreement that we reach
with them and something that i've got to
raise today
that we wrote to the company about a
couple of days back we really do believe
that sitting behind this dispute the
motives for this company is that they
are involved at the moment in secret
discussions um on a takeover of this
company on bringing in one of these
the same type of scenario private equity
investment group in this case a company
called visa from luxembourg um and they
are going to asset strip this company
they're going to abandon the universal
service and they want to turn royal mail
to make more profits for themselves and
the shareholders into another gig
economy employer and we are not going to
accept that
okay well we will certainly put that to
the company um in the meantime royal
mail will say that you've rejected a
deal you say it's two percent they say
it's 5.5 because they say that an extra
3.5 percent is is subject to agreement
on a series of changes so why are you
rejecting that
well that's pie in the sky and i'm sorry
to go back to the same thing it's simply
not true
that was
that offer as you call it was put to our
members directly by the company uh
before our members even voted in the
numbers that i just described earlier on
it is pie in the sky the two percent was
imposed two percent of that is
supposedly against a productivity scheme
that doesn't exist and nobody in the
company can sit in front of anybody in
the union and explain what it is our
members have got to do to earn that two
percent and the other 1.5 percent of
that is against a leveling down agenda
one of these piano style leveling down
agendas um which will destroy the post
office as we know it royal mail as we
know it and we're not going to accept it
i'm sorry to say
it's completely untrue what they're
saying to you and our members know that
postal workers would not be voting in
the numbers that they're voting in if
any of what you said was true but by the
way 5.5 percent uh even if it was there
is not enough against inflation and
against the
horrendous energy bills that our members
and millions of other people in this
country are going to be facing
dave water we're likely to see a general
strike in this country do you think
would you back one if there was one
called
look i'm not here to talk about a
general strike what i will say to you
is that you know i think people across
the uk uh every worker counts every
workers in the same position
and yes i think we should be looking at
cold and hated action we should be
looking to raise
issues around the way that uk companies
are being run the blatant profiteering
that's taking place across the uk
because not only are the workforce being
ripped off here but also customers are
being ripped off these are the people
who are causing the spiral and inflation
that's going on and something's got to
be done about the way that uk businesses
operate and royal mail is right at the
top of that list at the moment we've got
our sites on them you know it is time if
these people
are really only interested in further
profits for themselves then they should
resign from this company and get people
in who want to take forward this great
company that's been in existence over
500 years we'll deal with any change
we've accrued all change on technology
on automation so don't believe that the
stuff that they're putting out
and you know honestly get them on the on
the program with me
with our union and we'll debate all of
those issues live in front of the
british public
okay we'll put that invitation to them
we are speaking to uh royal mail a
little bit later on but dave ward we
appreciate your time thanks very much
indeed
thank you
time to check on what's happening in the
world of sport now here's jackie
thank you anna we start with a really
horrible image for liverpool fans this
morning the champions league group
stages draw has been made and real
madrid will defend their crown after
winning in a record 13th time last
season while liverpool lost to the
spanish giants in that final and this
year jurgen klopp side have been drawn
alongside rangers
it will be rangers first appearance in
the competition in more than a decade
after they won their playoff game
against psv eindhoven on wednesday
scottish champion celtic meanwhile have
been drawn in group f
as well
premier league champions manchester city
have been put into group g where they'll
come up against sevilla
and erling harlan's former club russia
dortmund the 2021 champions chelsea have
ac milan for company in group e while
spurs with europa league winners
frankfurt in group d
let's move on to tennis and emerald
akane has been handed a very tough draw
as she begins the defense of her u.s
open title against france's elise cornei
cam nori plays benoit pair of france and
andy murray starts against francisco
serendolo and could it be a last-ever
tournament for serena williams the
23-time grand slam champion faces danke
kovanich in the first round the year old
is looking to bid farewell to flushing
meadows with the seventh u.s open crown
novak djokovic will not take part in the
tournament because non-vaccinated
visitors are still banned in the united
states the wimbledon champion who's on
21 grand slam titles will miss the
chance to add to that tally
the goal for
rory mcelroy has recovered from very
tough starts in the tour championship at
east lake atlanta while scotty scheffler
bolstered his hopes of fedex cup victory
by extending his lead well mcelroy sent
his opening tee shot out of bounds on
his way to a triple bogey but an eagle
here on the sixth helped him to three
under on the day seven under overall
still in touch
[Applause]
that is always fought for now but i'll
be back with more in an hour's time
jackie thanks very much indeed so let's
go back to our breaking news this
morning on the new energy price cap
which will rise to
3549 pounds from october that's about an
80 rise i'm joined now to get reaction
by labour's shadow chancellor rachel
reeves so a very good morning to you
what do you make of this new price cap
well although it was expected that
doesn't um reduce the severity and the
seriousness of this announcement it will
strike fear into the hearts of families
and pensioners
right across
the country and that's why labour have
called for the government to take autumn
and winter and to pay for that with an
extension of the windfall tax on the
massive profits that north sea oil and
gas companies are continuing to make
that is the right and the fair thing to
do is what labour would do if we were in
government now
well yes and you've laid out your plans
this freeze on energy bills over the
winter but a lot of people say it's an
incredibly expensive and only short-term
fix
it's a package of measures worth 29
billion pounds and that includes the
price freeze that would mean that no one
would pay a penny more for their gas
electricity
this autumn and winter and it would also
mean for the four million customers who
are on prepayment meters who at the
moment pay more for their gas and
electricity than if you pay by direct
debit that they would no longer face
that premium which would help some of
the poorest people we would pay for this
through a package of um of revenue
raisers including eight billion pounds
from an extension of the windfall tax
14 billion pounds from repurposing
government announcements already
on
gas and electricity and 7 billion pounds
through the lower interest that would be
paid on government debt because these
measures directly reduce the headline
rate of inflation at which much
government debt
is dependent on
well yes you say 29 billion pounds but
is this fully funded i noticed that the
charity full fact today is raising some
questions about whether your plan
actually would cover this price cap rise
they say that your plan doesn't take
into account
most customers hire gas and electricity
consumption during the winter it's going
to be more expensive and it falls short
at the moment doesn't it
well last time full fat fat checked some
labor analysis they had to
withdraw it a couple of days later
because they'd got their numbers wrong i
i worked as an economist at the bank of
england for many years before i became a
member of parliament i'm confident about
my numbers i'm confident that they stack
up but most of all i am very confident
that the package of measures that we've
announced will make a real difference to
families and pensioners who are worried
sick about what is going to happen to
them this winter
it would also benefit a lot of people
that don't need the help why are you not
going for more targeted help for those
who need it most
well we know that people on lower
incomes spend three times as much on gas
and electricity as a share of their
income than the richest households so
this will have a disproportionate
positive impact on some of the poorest
families we also know that the four
million people who use prepayment meters
are some of the poorest families and
pensioners in our country and our
package offers an extra 300
um
to them over the winter months so we
think it helps those on the lowest
incomes the most but also i would say
this i've been speaking to leeds money
buddies a charity that's very active in
my constituency helping people
with financial difficulties that they
say that there are people coming to them
now who have never had financial
difficulties before but are now being
thrown into chaos and disarray by these
energy price increases the university of
york say that two-thirds of the
households now risk falling into fuel
poverty and so it is important that a
package of measures helps people beyond
those who are on benefits because the
fact is that these devastating increases
in prices are going to have impacts on
people right through the income
distribution our package is simple it
doesn't rely on rebates it just says the
prices won't go up beyond where they are
already and that will be funded in part
by that big increase in the windfall tax
to ensure that those people who are
making big profits are based on these
higher apologies rachel we're about to
fall off air i must thank you and say
thanks